hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve interleaving string so in
this problem we're given a list of three
strings well not really a list but we're
given three strings s1 s2 and s3 and we
just want to know a simple question can
we form the string s3 by interleaving
the strings s1 and s2 an interleaving
string is basically when you take two
strings and split them up into you know
sub strings and then you add them
together now they have a description
over here but i kind of feel like this
description actually just made things
more complicated for me like with the
absolute value difference being at most
one you know taking these strings
forming them together basically what
we're saying is can we take
the string
one and string two split them into sub
strings like you can see a string one is
split into this one this one and this
one and notice how the relative order of
these three is maintained that's very
important and this other string was also
split into two portions this one and
this one and the relative order of the
characters was maintained you can see
that this
dbc goes in the front and the a goes at
the end so the relative order is
important but that's it we can split the
strings in any way that we want and then
add them together and we just want to
know doing that can we form the third
string so the first thing you might
notice is well if we're taking the
string splitting them of course the
total number of characters has to match
the total number of characters in string
three and yes that's true it will have
to match and in this case it does we
have ten characters and the output in
each of these strings is five five plus
five equals ten so once you kind of
understand what an interleaving string
actually is the logic of this problem
isn't too complicated right for example
we see that the first character in
string three is a right so for sure we
need at least one of the characters from
s1 or s2 to start with an a right
because we can't just take an a from the
middle of one of these strings and then
say okay we'll put that at the beginning
because remember the relative order of
each of these strings has to be
maintained so at least one of them has
to start with an a and we can see that
the first string over here does start
with an a right so it's kind of brute
force we're just comparing the first
positions of each of the charac of the
input strings right so now we have a d
and we can choose between an a and a d
in either of the strings but we're
looking for an a in the target string so
we're going to again pick from the first
string and we can cross that out so now
we have another sub problem we have the
remaining portion of this and the and
the entire portion of this string right
so and we're kind of just brute forcing
it obviously if we got to a character
such you know let's say at this position
we had a z but you know when you look at
both of the strings that we have neither
of them have a z in that case it would
basically mean it's impossible for us to
continue at this point but what if we
had the opposite what if we had a b over
here and you can see that this position
is also a b right and let's say we were
looking for a b right so then which one
of these are we gonna take are we gonna
take the b from string two or the b from
string one that's the back tracking or
the brute force portion right we could
take either of them so we pretty much
have to make a decision in our decision
tree that we are gonna choose both we're
going to see if we do it either of these
ways is it possible for us to take these
two strings interleave them together to
build the output string right because
maybe one of the ways works but the
other way doesn't we do have to try both
of the ways but it turns out we can use
a dynamic programming technique called
caching where we can eliminate a bunch
of repeated work so therefore the time
complexity of the solution can actually
be broken down to m times n where m is
the size of one string and n is the size
of the other string and you can actually
instead of doing caching you can
actually do a true dynamic programming
solution that will also give you this
time complexity i'll explain a little
bit about both of those so let me just
kind of show you what the decision tree
for this problem would look like and
then how we're actually going to do the
caching so notice how we're going to
start at the beginning of both of the
strings and we're also going to start at
the beginning of the third string right
we're looking for this character can we
get it from either of string one or
string two right so that's kind of how
our decision tree is gonna work we're
gonna have one pointer let's call it i1
which is going to represent what
position we're at in s1 and we're gonna
have another pointer let's call it i two
it's a little bit messy but i2 is gonna
represent the position we're at in
string two and we're gonna have a third
pointer over here let's call it i3 right
but do you notice that this pointer is
always going to be the addition of i1
and i2 if we add these pointers together
we're always going to get this one right
because notice how you know they're both
initially at zero right zero plus zero
is going to equal zero which is the
first one here if we increment one of
them right if we take this pointer and
shift it over here this is gonna be one
so we're gonna take one plus zero add it
together and we're gonna get at the
position one which is gonna be over here
and that makes sense because if we use a
character from here that's gonna take up
the character that's over here so that's
kind of how the math works out so in
reality we just have to keep track of
two pointers the third pointer can be
calculated for the position of this
string so we start at the position zero
zero the first zero indicates what
position we're at over here second
pointer indicates where we're at over
here
and we're going to compare so does this
equal this character of course it does
write d does not equal a but a equals a
so we can shift our pointer over here
and shift our pointer over here so in
this case we didn't have to make two
decisions we just had an easy job we
just had to make one decision so let's
call that uh one zero because we shifted
our first pointer to the position one
and now i'm going to go kind of fast
because i think you probably get what
we're going to do so once again this is
the character
that matches in string three so we can
shift both of our pointers to the next
position and once again we incremented
the first pointer so we're going to be
at two
zero and in this case b does not match d
but this character does so once again
let's shift our pointers by one and in
this case we shifted the second pointer
so let's call that two
one i don't really know why i'm drawing
the decision tree like this but let's
continue so in this case you can see
we're looking for a b and we can get a b
from this one or from this one right so
that's gonna be two different decisions
we finally have two different decisions
we can either do three one or we can do
two
two depending on how we do it so this is
kind of where the complexity is going to
come right and the worst case would be
that we could make two decisions every
single time so you can see that if we
continue drawing this out the worst case
time complexity for a particular uh
decision tree could be 2 to the power of
n plus m basically the total number of
characters that we have but you can see
that we might be repeating the same sub
problem multiple times right how many
different possible pairs of values could
we even have like this well we could
only have n different values in the
first position we could have m different
values in the second position that's
where the time complexity n by m comes
from so we can do this by caching i'm
going to show you how we can do that in
the coding portion so this will make
sure that we have this many sub problems
and if we repeat the same sum problem we
can just do it in o of one time because
we're going to be caching the result of
that now what exactly is the value that
we're going to be caching well for any
particular sub problem like for either
of these branches we want to know
ultimately from here are we actually
able to form the remaining portion of
the result string so either it's going
to be true or false right we're not
storing a value like a number or
anything we're going to be storing true
or false for any of these and actually
if we find a single true then we don't
have to cache it because if we find a
single true that means we are able to
form the result string and then we can
immediately return true by going back up
to the root that we called this
recursive function from so we discussed
the memoization solution but let's go
over the true dynamic programming
solution which is going to be pretty
similar to what we just talked about so
just to quickly go over what was the
base case in our recursive solution that
we went over well what what would happen
if let's say the the last uh pointer in
the first string reached this position
out of bounds and the pointer of string2
reached this position that would mean if
we added them together we would get to
the out of bounds position in s3 right
so basically if both of the pointers
become out of bound that's how you know
we have reached the base case and in
that case that means we built the
resulting string and we can return true
so when we go over to the dynamic
programming solution take a look at this
grid that i've drawn you might recognize
this as a regular dynamic programming
grid this is string one this is string
two we multiplied them together because
remember it's m by n that's what our
cache is going to look like so i'm
basically drawing what the cache looks
like but you can see that this is the
dimensions but i have one extra layer
out here which is important in this
problem remember what i just said if
this if we're out of bounds in this
string and we're out of bounds in this
string that's going to lead us to this
position so that's our base case we want
to initialize this with a t for true and
a particular value in this grid for
example this one means that let's say we
had this remaining portion of the string
and we had this remaining portion of the
string you can see that both of these
together form a str form two different
characters right two characters in total
so what we're asking is if you look at
the last two characters in our resulting
string we want to know can these two
characters a and c form this string
a c right that's the target string that
we're looking for can these two
characters form it of course by looking
at them you can tell yes they can form
this string right but that's basically
what we're going to be computing we're
going to be doing that for every single
cell in this 2d grid and yes we're even
gonna have to calculate these out of
bounds positions why is it that we have
to do that because they're actually
valid positions take a look at this
position this means if we had zero
characters from string one but we had a
single character from string two meaning
you know the character a can we form the
last character of the target string well
the last character on the target string
is c
this character is a so therefore we
can't do that right so we have to put a
false over here and similarly from this
position we're looking at just these
last two characters c a using these
characters can we form the target string
a c you might think yes but no we can't
because remember the relative order of
these characters has to match this first
character c has to match this character
but it doesn't so this is also going to
be a false right and of course we would
do the same thing for this position
right computing this if we had a c from
here but we had nothing from here in
that case this is actually going to be a
true because we have a value here for an
arbitrary position like this let me just
show you what's going to happen
obviously this mat this is a b here and
we have a b in this portion as well so
if we take the indices of these which is
two plus two we get to index four in our
target string which is this target
character right we're looking for a b
now notice how either of these can get
there if we used the b from
this position
like this b what would we do in that
case well then we'd want to know okay we
if we were able to get a b now does the
result in the bottom position equal true
why are we looking in the bottom
position because we just used this b so
we can't use it again we have to use
these last two characters but we can use
this first b if we want to because we
didn't use it yet so in that case we
would go down in the opposite case if we
used this b we cross it out we can still
use this one but we can only use two
characters from here so in that case we
would go to the right now if either of
these in this case we can go in both
directions if either the bottom neighbor
is true or the right neighbor is true
then we can put true in this position if
they were both false then we can't put
false if only then we can't put true if
only one of them was true then we can
also put true now let's dive into the
coding portion so in the interest of
time i'm just going to skip and show you
what the memoization recursive solution
looks like and then we're going to code
up the dynamic programming solution so
we do have a cache in this case it's
going to be a hashmap and you can see
we're passing in two pointers into our
function just like we did in the drawing
right and our base case is yes if i and
j are out of bounds then we can return
true that's one base case another base
case is if this position has already
been computed meaning it's already in
the dynamic programming cache then we
can just return the result now if that's
not the case then we have to go into our
recursive case you might not be able to
tell but yes this is recursion because
we're checking if i is still in bounds
right because technically one of the
strings could be out of bounds so if i
is in bounds then we're gonna check does
the character in string one i basically
is the pointer for string one does that
character match the target position
we're looking at in string three like i
said we're taking i plus j the two
pointers adding them together to find
the target character in string three so
if the characters match then we're gonna
take i and increment it by one right
we're incrementing it by one because
we're saying we just used the character
from string one now the next two lines
of code are the exact opposite if the
string if the character if the pointer
in string two is inbounds and that
character in string two matches the
target character then we're gonna take
dfs and increment j by one saying we
just used the character in string two
and if that returns true then we can
return true in either of these cases we
don't have to cache that because if we
find one valid result then we can
immediately return true from the root
function if neither of them return true
then we have to dp cache this as false
and then return false because we don't
have to repeat the work again so that's
the entire function i bet it's a little
bit easier than you expected and then
all we have to do is call dfs starting
at the beginning of both strings 0 0. so
now let's do the dp portion and the
first thing i'm going to do is just make
sure that the length of the strings add
up to the length of the target string so
if length of string two and string three
add up to the length of string one then
we can return
false if they don't add up let me make
that correction if they don't add up
then we return false otherwise we can
continue so otherwise we can actually uh
basically so otherwise we can initialize
our dp two-dimensional array i'm just
going to copy paste that in the interest
of time so remember we're just gonna
initialize this as basically empty in
other words we're gonna initialize
everything as false and the dimensions
are going to be basically the length of
string one and string two plus one
remember because we do need that outside
layer so that's just what this is doing
you could do this differently in other
languages and for the out of bounds
position like the out of bounds position
in both strings string one and string
two we want to initialize that corner
value as true remember just like in the
drawing position the drawing picture and
i don't know if i mentioned this in the
drawing but we are going to start at the
bottom right corner and then work our
way to the left and then work our way up
row by row so that's what these two are
uh these two for loops are indicating
it's a nested loop we're starting at the
bottom right working our way to the top
left now the rest of this code is
actually going to be very much borrowed
from what we just did in the recursive
solution so i'm actually just going to
copy and paste these two lines to show
you it's actually very similar to the
recursive solution so what exactly do we
need to change the same thing is true if
i is in bounds because remember one of
these strings could be one of these
pointers could be out of bounds because
we are uh computing some of those
out-of-bound corner positions right so
if i is still in bounds then we want to
check okay does that character equal to
the target character we're looking for
if it does we don't want to compute dfs
right but we want to know if the result
of this is true but we can do that from
our dp right we're not doing recursion
we're just using our dp value and since
we're computing this bottom up we know
that the result of this will already be
computed so instead of saying dfs let's
change this to dp of i plus 1
and j
so if this happens to be true then what
are we going to do we're not going to
return true right because we're not
doing this recursively we're going to
set dp of i and j whatever we're
currently at in this for loop and then
set it equal to true right again for
these bottom two lines we're going to do
the exact same so instead of calling dfs
if j is still in bounds and the
character at j equals the character
we're looking for we're not going to
call dfs we want to know is dp of these
two pointers still
true so we're going to say i dp of i and
dp of j plus 1. if that's true then we
can set our dp position to true it's
possible that both of these if
statements will execute that isn't a
problem for us right we'll set it to
true either way now if neither of these
if statements executes we want to set
our dp position equal to false but
notice how we already initialized the
entire 2d grid to false right so we
actually don't need to do that third
condition
and i know i kind of pretty much just
cheated by copy and pasting a bunch of
this but that's the entire code i'm not
kidding so once you do that
nested for loop we can just return the
result of dp at position zero zero
that's the entire code so yes this
solution works it's efficient and we
just and i just showed you how to solve
it in two different ways so i hope this
was helpful if it was please like and
subscribe it supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching